Okay, I think we're ready to really test your
knowledge of what we learned in this lesson. There are
a lot of really awesome concepts that we've learned really
in all the lessons up to this point. And we
can start building an entire framework around how to understand
particular traits. Let's use an example that combines the concepts
of mutation selection and allelic frequency. The CCR5 gene is
located on human chromosome three and it produces a protein,
the CCR5 protein, that you can see here
in green. And it resides on the surface of
T-cells. T-cells are immune cells that fight infection. Now,
although T-cells do a pretty good job at fighting
infection, in fact they do an amazing job really.
There's a virus out there that can really take
them out. It's called HIV, or the Human Immuno-deficiency
virus. You might have heard of it before. The
HIV virus binds really well to this protein called CCR5. And when it does,
the whole complex gets internalized. And this is how HIV gets inside T-cells. It
hijacks this protein and uses it to get inside the T-cell, infect it. And
then infect the entire immune system. So if you have a normally functioning CCR5
allele, then you're at risk for HIV
infection. However, there's an allele of CCR5 that
creates a very dysfunctional version of the
protein, rendering it pretty much non-functional, and it
can't even get to the cell surface
of T-cells. Without that CCR5 protein, the HIV
simply can't get in the T-cells. The T-cells
are thus resistant to HIV infection. So here's
your first question using this example. Is the
mutation for the dysfunctional protein that makes the T-cell
HIV resistant more likely in the coding or non-coding
DNA of the genome? I want you to check
one of these boxes and then explain why you
think that's the answer in this text box here.
I want you to save your answer, because guess
what, you're going to need it in the next video.